hey guys dr berg here i want to share
some real interesting things
about wheatgrass that you've probably
never heard before okay now the first
question is
what is wheatgrass well it's not the
grass that grows in your backyard okay
it actually comes from the wheat plant
so
wheatgrass is baby wheat okay it's the
stuff
that they eventually can turn into flour
that they that you can buy at the
grocery store that they make bread
and pasta and cereal and donuts and
cookies right
that's what they make and they sell
white bread and wheat bread the whole
thing okay
so that's the flour this is made from
the grain or the seed
the seed is what has the gluten in it
okay that's what creates a lot of
digestive issues
and people have inflammation from it
they get all sorts of digestive damaging
damage now this is a baby wheatgrass
plant
this is at the stage where it's well
before
the seeds are going to grow so you have
no gluten
in this stage whatsoever so there's no
gluten in wheatgrass juice powder
only in the actual seed that's grounded
into flour okay so that's one thing that
people have a confusion about
but the cycle of a plant when you have a
seed or
a grain it grows into this plant this is
the reason why they capture the wheat
grass is that this is the peak nutrition
for phytonutrients and nutrition
right when it gets about this size about
four four to six inches
that's when you have the most nutrition
in the cycle of growing wheat
okay so the next thing i want to talk
about is what's the difference between
the powder okay wheatgrass
powder and wheatgrass juice powder
okay real big difference very
interesting
number one is that if you take one of
these
grass i don't know if you've ever done
this and you chewed on some grass
what happens you can actually crunch it
there's some crunchiness what is that
crunchiness
you're basically grinding with your
teeth this
fiber and there's little pockets of
of wheatgrass that's in there a juice
i'm sorry and the juice is being
released with all the nutrition so all
their nutrition is inside little pockets
so it's like little air bubbles
it's very similar to bubble wrap
okay so i'm sorry to chew this bubble
wrap i'm not going to chew it
you could actually start to hear the
crunching
so when you're chewing this you're
actually releasing the nutrition okay
so the problem is that
wheatgrass is mostly 99.99
of its fiber it's a cellulose
this fiber does not digest in a human
digestive tract
a cow has a very specific enzyme to
break down
this grass we do not so when you buy
wheatgrass
powder you're basically buying the fiber
mostly because when you consume it you
don't have the enzyme to extract the
nutrition
and it's captured in there it's kind of
like eating hay and that's really what
hay does
hay is like dried out grass and you feed
it to
you know horses and things like that so
there's not
nearly the amount of nutrition in
chlorophyll in the
grass powder and the wheatgrass juice
powder there is
no fiber okay it's all nutrition it's
extracted and it's preserved
so it's a hundred percent absorbable
okay so that would be
the one difference now it takes
this entire entire tray of wheatgrass
to make one heaping teaspoon of this
stuff
okay so i'll show you
so this right here is equivalent
to this entire tray without the fiber
so it's super concentrated it's like
over 2
000 percent more concentrated okay
so this is like 25
this is 58 cents and the reason we're
able to do that is because we do this in
massive
quantities so the difference is this is
mainly fiber
this is more nutrition and this is a lot
more convenient because
the amount of effort it would take to
juice this
with the juicer and then clean it oh my
gosh
going to the store buying the wheatgrass
juice incredibly
not very convenient okay so anyway
okay so those three very unique things
about
the wheatgrass that we have that i want
to share with you the most amazing thing
is how it's grown we basically take
seeds we take wheat berries we take the
seed of the wheat
and we grow them in late fall okay
so the snow comes it covers them
and it doesn't actually become this high
until may
so that's six months it's sitting in the
earth and what is it doing it's growing
roots
so the specific type of wheatgrass that
we grow
has a root structure that digs deep into
the earth
pulling all the nutrition up into that
plant so that's number one
this stuff is grown within six to ten
days look at this this root structure
it's like
it's just like basically fiber there's
no root structure
and a lot of times wheatgrass from the
healthy store that grows
mold well this stuff is very clean
because the nutrition protects it
against the molds and the viruses and
the bacteria
and insects that whole thing that's what
really see a weak plant will be
susceptible to
bugs and microbes even if there's a
vitamin deficiency
so we don't have to worry about a
vitamin deficiency with this so we have
a combination
of the processing of the seed
secondly where it's grown it's grown in
an ancient seabed what does that mean
it's an old ocean floor
okay what's significant about that is
that there's all these trace minerals in
there there's like
93 trace minerals those are the minerals
that are
pulled into the root structure so you're
getting a product that's
so super enhanced with all of the
minerals
like this does not have the trace
minerals this
does okay so we have how it's grown
we also have where it's grown on and
lastly and most importantly
converting this grass into this powder
is very very unique so the company
that i work with use this process called
bioactive dehydration okay it's a very
unique patented process where they
basically take the juice of this
and within minutes turn into powder
using very low heats
so when they juice it the problem is
that all the enzymes
all the oils the fat soluble vitamins
the essential fatty acids in this grass
the vitamin e
complexes are very fragile to oxygen and
heat
so number one we have to do this fast so
it's quickly converted into a powder
within minutes
under low heat nothing above 106 degrees
and even for one minute so we have a
it's only heated for
um like 106 degrees for one minute and
then the temperature goes down
and it turns into a powder so what
you're getting right here
is a raw live product in a powdered form
when it becomes a powder the enzymes are
preserved and protected
so all you have to do is add water to
this
so i'll show you to activate the enzymes
so it's basically alive
so i'm going to take this put a teaspoon
now one one thing with my other
wheatgrass juice powder and i didn't
talk about this
is that um i would say put it in a
glass and stir it there's a lot of
clumping that occurs with that
so i'm gonna highly recommend you get a
shaker bottle
okay tighten it up and you shake it
this gets 100 of it in the form that's
really smooth with no clumping okay look
at this thing
this is like liquid health liquid life
so then you can actually drink this
and it's very very refreshing okay so
number one
the seeds are grown for six months in
the soil which allows for the root
structure
secondly you have where it's grown on
ancient seabeds
third you have the bioactive dehydration
where we convert
this into this within minutes
so as to protect the enzymes and all the
other delicate nutrition
okay so there's a couple other unique
benefits
what i did with this wheatgrass is i
added
uh what's called kamut wheatgrass what
is kamut wheatgrass
well there's a kind of a story a
background story in 1949 this air man
was in
egypt and apparently he was visiting the
the pyramids and uh he came back
uh with some wheat berries that he found
in some
tomb of some pharaoh okay and he shipped
them back to montana where they started
to grow them
basically they found the ancient wheat
berry and that's why they call it
sometimes
king tut's wheat and that's what kamut
is
when other people take kamu to make
flour and make bread
even though it has gluten because it's a
seed
they don't seem to have the inflammation
or the digestive issues so that's very
interesting that the
ancient grain doesn't create the
reaction like you would get you know at
your local store
but what they did is they the company i
work with basically take the seed of
kamut and it grows it
same soil same process but we added 25
percent commute into this and the reason
why i wanted to do that is because
kamut has some unique health additional
health back factors number one it has
tons of selenium
selenium is great for the thyroid in
converting
t4 into t3 especially if someone has
hashimoto's okay
secondly it's really uh loaded with more
protein
okay and a lot of other phytonutrients
so i kind of spiked this even
more than my other version which is kind
of a plain version with more nutrition
then we added an organic natural lemon
flavor
with a hint of stevia so when you
consume this
it's it just it's delicious okay it's
like a lemon drink it doesn't taste bad
at
all uh and it's like quite amazing okay
so to make it
easier to drink and then two other
things number one
it's very convenient you don't have to
get a juicer you just take this around
take a teaspoon teaspoon stick it in
here it has a little scooper in there as
well
get a shaker bottle that's going to be
important shake it up and drink it
some people do it in the morning some
people do at night some people do it
morning and
night if you take one serving it'll last
you
60 days okay the cost per serving
is 58 cents this is 25 okay so it's
it's a we're able to bring the cost down
because we get it in bulk
i have to order a year in advance
of this stuff because how it's seasonal
and they have to grow it i can't just
order it tomorrow i have to wait
and then i have to make sure that's why
i keep running out of this stuff because
it's such a great product people and
then i have to wait until it comes back
okay and i put a link in the description
box so you can get more information
about this
and then send me your comments thank you
so much for watching
hey guys thank you so much for watching
please click the subscribe button
and i will see you in the next video